[موسيقى]
تعيش أمريكا على الأموال المقترضة ،
ولهذا السبب يتم طرح مصطلحات الديون والعجز
كثيرًا ولكنهما بالطبع
ليسا نفس الشيء ، فلنبدأ أولاً
بتعريفاتنا إذا كانت
الحكومة تنفق أكثر مما تأخذ في
هذا المعطى هنا الفرق  يسمى
دين عجز أو دين V هو المبلغ
الإجمالي للمنازل الحكومية ، لذلك كل عام في
العجز يزداد الدين بشكل أكبر بالنظر إلى
الرسم البياني نرى أنه في عام 1950 كان الدين
حوالي 257 مليار دولار
مقارنة الآن بحوالي 22 تريليون
دولار  لكن مقارنة النطاق المسدود
بمقارنة الديون الآن يشبه إلى حد ما
مقارنة التفاح بالبرتقال ،
وذلك لأنه عندما تتحدث عن العجز
تحتاج إلى سياق وأول شيء يجب أن
تضعه في الاعتبار التضخم مع التضخم
أن 257 مليار دولار من الديون في عام 1950
أصبحت فجأة 2.8 تريليون.  في أموال اليوم ،
ولكن عليك أيضًا النظر إلى
الحجم الإجمالي للاقتصاد ،
فقد نما اقتصادنا بشكل هائل منذ عام 1950 ،
لدينا المزيد من الأموال ، لدينا المزيد من الأصول
لدينا المزيد  هذا هو السبب في أنه عندما
يتحدث الاقتصاديون عن الدين الذي
يفضلون استخدام هذا الرقم ، فإن نسبة الدين إلى
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي تأخذ إجمالي الدين العام
وتوضح حجمه بالنسبة إلى
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي ، لذا إذا عدنا الآن
إلى مقارنة الديون هذه وبدلاً من ذلك
أظهر الدين كنسبة مئوية من
إجمالي الاقتصاد حسنًا ، إنها قصة مختلفة
بالنسبة لنا  الرقم في الوقت الحالي هو
حوالي مائة وستة في المائة
وهو أعلى رقم منذ الحرب العالمية
الثانية ، وإذا كنت تتساءل عما إذا كان هذا
الرقم مرتفعًا جدًا ، فلا توجد
إجابة بسيطة يقول بعض الاقتصاديين إن 85 في
المائة منها مرتفع جدًا والبعض يقول مائة في
المائة  يقول البعض أنه أعلى
بغض النظر عن الرقم الصحيح
يتفق الاقتصاديون على أن هذه هي الأرقام
التي يجب أن تبحث عنها